runners at the corners now for cleveland
big curveball indoors running throw gets
into center field ramirez will score
frankie gets up he goes to third it's
one nothing cleveland on a rare miscue
by gold glove catcher yadier molina
so a couple of the walks and now a heck
of a lot of trouble here in this first
inning
launched deep right field
wow and go on to the empty bleachers
must be on the road huh ron miller reyes
loves that road cooking
his seventh home run of the year
and he now has 21 runs driven in tied
with jose ramirez for the team lead and
the indians have a four nothing first
inning advantage
and that is a ball and that may be it
and it will be mike schilt is going to
go to his pen
it's a tough night for daniel ponce de
leon jake woodford will come on
and daniel cannot get out of the first
and a swing and a miss
so the indians strike for four runs all
of them earned here in the first inning
kristen mckenzie what a breath of fresh
air this young man is
colton wong to center delino runs and
dives and makes the catch for route
number one
left a nice little divot out in the
outfield but had a good jump on it
coming in puts it out for out number one
nice play mckenzie trying to get through
this first inning without allowing the
cardinals to yeah get on the board
regaining the momentum
in the air left field playable for
luplow
no runs two hits two left we've played
one in st louis indians at the corners
with nobody else
and that goes to first goldschmidt's
coming home with the throw
and they've got hernandez in a rundown
tag him out and now ramirez is oh
well they've got a miss no nobody's
around oh he got mad my goodness
that was just yeah bad base running a
nice play by molina four nothing indians
lindor's at second
two down in the second
high fly ball deep right field back is
fowler he's at the wall he's out of room
it's out of here
carlos santana with a two out two run
homer
and all is that a huge turn of events
for the tribe
as they extend their lead to six to
nothing and it brings in a dexter follow
follow
two homers seven rbis
lifted in the air deep right field off
the bat of fowler it is gone into the
cardinal bullpen
dexter fowler on jackie robinson day
with a two-run homer that will mean
something to dexter fowler in ways
we can only imagine wearing number 42
big fly
dexter tristan mckenzie on the mound for
the tribe tonight his second appearance
in the big leagues
live ball center field
and tristan mckenzie cruises through the
third one ball two strikes
here's the one-two swing gonna miss
strike three
got him with
that harder breaking pitch that time
o'neil down on strikes
swung on and missed he blew it by him
upstairs
so tyler naquin steps in with a runner
in scoring position
drilled deep right back his fowler and
it is off the pole a two-run homer
and the indians strike again their third
home run of the evening
man it's an 8-2 indians advantage well
they're loaded up now and big man from
neil reyes oh he drills that one into
center field that'll get two more home
and it's 10-2 cleveland and it's a
five-rbi night for front neil reyes the
pitch
swung on line drive base hit center
field
santana hits third he's coming home the
throw to the plate over the
catcher and the indians now lead 11-2
the pitch
and it's swung on rifled inside the bag
at third down the left-field line by
delano de shields hits off the sidewall
carrum's back into play in the score
is from mio reyes roberto perez to third
and delano de shields has his third hit
and the indians now lead 12 to two
and that's in the air to left field
jordan luplow makes the catch that'll do
it the indians stomp the cardinals 14-2